foreign
hello there multiversis continues to
pump out new Fighters at an astonishing
rate the most recent update brings
stripe to the battlefield the Gremlins
icon himself as is our ritual let's go
through Stripes Origins and find out
where his moveset was first seen get
ready for some 1980s and 90s Nostalgia
let's do this When selecting stripe in
the menu he can be seen breaking out of
his pod to show he originally came from
Gizmo Gizmo gets wet Gizmo spawns Mogwai
mogwai's eat after midnight Gremlins are
created Gremlins touch sunlight Gremlins
melt it's the circle of life by the way
this is what stripe looks like as a
normal Mogwai super cute the Mohawk is
his calling card and in the movie he ate
chicken after midnight and thus became
the stripe we all know today
the majority of Stripes moves come from
an epic fight scene at the end of the
first movie as the very last Gremlin
alive he makes One Last Stand in a
department store the skateboard movies
here thanks to Stripes mode of Transport
around the store admit it he can
skateboard better than you his muttering
is a little bit weird though
well maybe he is he isn't the greatest
after all when he loses a match his
animation will show him falling over his
skateboard and I don't think giving
himself concussion helps much either
Stripes win animation on the other hand
is a homage to another mode of Transport
his repositioning skills in the store he
uses a child's trike in a battle to the
death he knows how to be cool Under
Pressure moments before this stripe uses
another move from the game throwing saw
blades bare-handed like a complete
badass and if you need more detail they
are seven and a quarter inch blades
[Music]
in-game stripe is brilliant at wielding
these things and FYI the blade will roll
down the side of the map to knock off
those people who wall clink too long
very useful in game strike will throw
out a Boombox and shoot a crossbow at it
this may seem like a really weird Choice
yet it does have meaning in the movie
stripe has Billy pinned down and shoots
a bolt right through his arm
to block the next shot Billy raises up a
Boombox for protection
back up
not to be beaten stripe next charges
with a chainsaw in hand which is yet
another move that we find in multiverses
the bright yellow chainsaw is Iconic
even though it's only in the movie for a
few seconds and actually he's dragged
away from Bright Lights by it so
technically it saved his life I can see
why he kept it around
[Music]
oh and that actually brings us to the
Dodge animation which briefly makes
stripe dizzy it turns out it does happen
in the Gremlins movie when stripe hits
his head on the wall following that
chainsaw ride listen up and you'll hear
the Looney Tunes twittering Birds
[Applause]
[Music]
the gun stripe wields in the game is the
next weapon he finds in the movie
spotting the handgun in a display
cabinet before climbing to the top of a
water fountain and firing repeatedly his
multiverse's aim has improved remarkably
whereas in the Gremlins film he has to
be really up close and personal to hit a
shot like that time at the poker table
Stripes basic combo includes many
slashes and at the end there can be a
lunging bite in Gremlin stripe takes a
few digs with his nails but the second
film seems to be the real inspiration
here there's a jump scare with that bite
animation are you ready for the jump
scare time zone I mean it's always
midnight somewhere
this is Mohawk who is the Incarnation of
stripe in the second Gremlins movie he
eats through a freaking steel
workstation latches onto a random dude
and takes swipes at everyone around them
and even finishes with a sweet right
hook
I don't think that's in the game yet
stripe has the ability to bring out TNT
and I really struggle to find this in
the films I even scanned these pack
scenes for the culprit and here it is
there's a bunch of demolition Gremlins
of course and the explosion was lightly
inspired when a cinema went boom in the
first film
speaking of that Dynamite stripe has his
alternative attire uses it after a loss
he tries to catch it and accidentally
swallows it instead come on we've all
been there at some point this is likely
a nod to the countless times the Looney
Tunes have eaten explosives and remember
Warner Bros controls both those entities
they were so closely entwined at one
point that the Looney Tunes introduced
Gremlins too and in that movie one of
the Gremlins gets a WB tattoo a more
modern version of swallowing explosives
can be found in The Mask movie remember
that Stanley ipkiss would be a great
character in this game I'm getting
sidetracked back on point Stripes
alternative attire when winning goes
back to his trusty chainsaw with this
epic pose and just like the movie it
runs away again luckily he lets go this
time and has a little giggle to himself
and finally emoting with stripe lets us
hear a ton of voice lines he'll say
things like
the mean green fighting machine was the
nickname of Lou ferrigno's version of
the Hulk it was the nickname of the
Tide's Mutant Ninja Turtles before
donkey gave that title to Shrek You're a
Mean Green fight machine together we'll
scare the spit at it by the crosses us
and now stripe has stepped up to claim
it for himself
another line feels like a very
deliberate tease to another character
that has to be coming to multiverses
sometime in the future
get over here he has to be talking about
Scorpion from Mortal Kombat get over
here
you're getting over my head again what
do you think
right I think I got everything how did I
do if I missed anything please let me
know and I'll add it to the next episode
of 69 video game Easter eggs by the way
you should totally check out the other
videos in this series because my
self-esteem needs a boost thank you
kindly I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see
you next time
foreign